you will you always you play a lot of
dark characters yeah and it's funny
hanging out with you here and knowing
you're such like a light you're so fun
you're so easy to talk to you've seen
you don't seem like an evil person but
then I watch a movie
like the boy behind the door oh yeah
that was fun and I was like here's
what's funny
I I wasn't I don't know for what reason
but I didn't place it I wasn't I was
watching you but I wasn't it was you
were so good I'm not guys the boy behind
the door it's one of these little
independent movies that's really well
directed yeah she's phenomenal you were
so effed up I so effed up and I had to
look you up who's this oh it's her
because you were so crazy so crazy and I
was I was just blown away it really gosh
if I was uh if I was directing something
and I was considering some your agent
should send a scene from that or go
watch this movie you could see what she
does she doesn't need to read for you
right that's the kind of movie that was
that performed uh I haven't seen it
because I hate watching myself oh are
you another one of those actors who
doesn't like watching themselves have
you ever watched yourself yes
um
well and mainly for the podcast
now I'm having to watch the show like
five times do you like yourself I do you
know I do Pamela I like Pam
Pam you know it really is better
watching it and and I've seen there's
another little movie I did
um the story of Luke was it
um but an autistic kid and I watched
some scenes of that and you see yourself
when you're looping
but
I really love that little movie too
I love playing an evil character so I I
love it right I love it right isn't it
great it's fun it's fun it's more
interesting especially when there's
backstory there's subtext there's yeah
you know and always I always tell people
this that they ask or an actor asks me
it's like it's it's the the easiest
thing to do yeah is just act like you're
bad right and that's never the thing to
do right it's not interesting so true if
you play against it yeah the lines are
good enough yes it should come through
that's it you shouldn't have to do too
much that's right you shouldn't have to
twirl the mustache right and so there's
stuff where they're like no we want you
to be bad like I was talking you know we
do a talk fill uh podcast about
Smallville Tom and I and Ryan and I was
just talking about one of the actresses
on an episode she was a guest star but
she played it like she was supposed to
be the [ __ ] high school student yeah
she's like I am popular and this and I'm
like oh my God why is she playing it so
on the character uh caricaturist
characteristic yeah knows yes and you
know it's just like anyway that's yeah
but I love it yes you got to play it
with it it makes it much more
interesting and you know that's the
thing with the right